pour en parler benoît morel le président
de l'association québécoise des
pharmaciens propriétaires bonsoir
monsieur murray
bonsoir on peut commencer par un petit
cours alors ça commence par à quoi ça
sert ce médicament exactement
évidemment ça sert à traiter le coroner
virus donc il faut être positif dans un
premier temps fou c'est la condition
principale pour avoir eu un résultat de
test positif soit pcr ou plus facilement
d'un test rapide il faut aussi avoir une
condition de santé particulière par
exemple a été non vaccinés et avoir une
maladie chronique ou est âgé de 60 ans q
si vous êtes adéquatement vacciner c'est
à dire deux doses et vous avez pas de
vous avez quelques maladies chroniques
vous n'êtes pas éligibles donc c'est
vraiment les non vaccinés en premier et
les gens à haut risque d'hospitalisation
donc immunosupprimées qui n'ont pas bien
réagi aux vaccins ou qui ont des
conditions de santé très précaire oui je
veux juste qu'on se comprenne bien ici
parce que ça va vite là les gens
vaccinés mais qui ont des conditions de
santé particulière ils peuvent aussi
avoir accès ce médicament dans l'épaule
pour la majorité d'entre eux tandis que
par exemple où vous avez quelqu'un qui a
reçu ces deux doses qui fait du diabète
et partant du cholestérol il n'est pas
éligible à recevoir le pack solide si il
a reçu deux doses et il est imminent
supprimé lors ils pourraient être
éligibles parce que on n'est pas certain
si les vaccins auront bien fonctionné
dans cette situation là et donc ça
s'adresse en premier chez les non
vaccinés qui eux au dessus de 60 ans
peuvent le recevoir même si on pas de
maladies chroniques et si en rayon des
maladies chroniques ils ont en mode 60
ans ils peuvent aussi recevoir le pack
solide bon est-ce qu'il faut avoir des
gros symptômes ou si on sait on est
positif on notait sont s on voit bien
qu'on est positif c'est qu'on n'a pas
trop de symptômes
ça sert à rien
non c'est pas en lien avec les symptômes
d'une très bonne question c'est plutôt
en lien avec le risque qu'on a de
développer des complications donc dès
l'apparition des symptômes
vous faites un test il est positif vous
le pharmacien vous ne courrez pas le
pharmacien à la pharmacie parce que vous
êtes positif donc vous isoler et si vous
pensez que vous êtes d'un groupe à
risque là vous appelez vous n'êtes pas
par exemple adéquatement vaccinez vous
avez reçu une seule dose ou claude vous
avez un pharmacien il faut qu'on ait
rendez vous avec vous pour faire une
entrevue pour voir si vous pouvez les
recevoir parce qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup d'interactions avec d'autres
médicaments il émet des attractions
majeures qui vont rendre qui vont rendre
le traitement impossible donc pour
valider sur dans un premier temps ici on
peut vous le donner mais à ce moment là
le pharmacien offert une prescription et
vous envoyer quelqu'un cherchait où ils
vous l'envoie par là une raison non mais
on comprend bien vous ne vous présentez
pas à la pharmacie si vous avez un test
positif dans toutes les situations de
toute façon vous allez pas dans un lieu
public quand vous êtes te poses s'est
fait l'écho vide si on attend
oui parce que effectivement vous voulez
pas devenir un lieu de contagion non
plus dans les pharmacies ça se comprend
bien si on attend trop longtemps avant
de contacter le pharmacien l'on ne test
positif on pensait que ça irait bien
mais finalement ça vaut de moins en
moins bien est ce qu un moment où ça
sert plus à rien de prendre les
médicaments parce que justement on
attend trop longtemps
mais actuellement on peut le donner à
l'intérieur de cinq jours depuis le
début des symptômes donc vaut vraiment
calculé cinq jours même si vous avez
fait le test à la 2e journée c'est à
partir du début des symptômes et après
ça ça ne vaut plus la peine de faire le
traitement ça dit ça ne diminue pas
vraiment les risques mais essayez de
vous poser la question ce que je fais
partie des groupes à risque pour savoir
pourrait pour bien faire la démarche au
moment où vous allez avant votre
résultat de tests positifs vous le savez
vous êtes dans un groupe à risque vous
contacter le pharmacien parce que le
plus tôt serait le mieux le plus vite
vous allez faire le traitement le plus
vite le pack service vous avez avec
guérir la maladie a prévenu ses
complications alors très bien donc mieux
vaut peut-être même y penser c'est
former un petit peu même si on n'est pas
malade juste pour savoir si jamais on
contactera covin comment bien réagir
alors il faut connaître son état de
santé bien entendu peut-être poser
quelques
connaître son statut vaccinal évidemment
de notre port complètement vaccinés avec
les toutes premières doses il ya de
bonnes chances que vous fassiez partie
du gros clubs éligibles benoît moret
merci beaucoup pour l'entrevue
merci au revoir au revoir